we have raised winners winner after
winner after winner after winner listen
Abby we know you have your own special
way of teaching your students but would
it really be so bad to ease up a little
bit your dancers didn't meet your
expectations all season long and many of
their moms had a bone to pick with you
you had a lot to deal with this season
and studio 19 didn't make it any easier
so we totally get it if you're feeling a
little frazzled but don't drag the kids
into it hasn't been easy
from tearful fights - mommy meltdowns
and everything in between
check out the 10 most dramatic moments
from Dance Moms season eight you
probably won't be surprised to find out
that one of Michelle's meltdowns snagged
the number one spot let's jump right in
that's the only way parents wake up
Jenna Nina it's no secret that Janina is
a star but sometimes she can be a little
entitled and it drives a be crazy in
this extended scene we see Abby lose it
on Janina Abby's temper hits the ceiling
when Janina asks her why she didn't get
a solo Abby's reply is more than a
little feisty causing Joanne to come to
Jim Nina's rescue Joanne is tired of
Abby calling Jin mean our brat which
only makes things worse talk about drama
there's no I in team in season 8 episode
7 the girls were given a group dance
about sorority hazing but things been a
little south when Janina messed up her
counts in season eight Janina asked Ana
and Presley why they didn't help her out
more before the show and Presley fired
back when Eliana came in you and Ellie
just have a clip and the girls told
Janina that if she hadn't been so busy
befriending Eliana they would have works
better as a team a tearful Hanna Abby
might be hard on her dancers but if
there's one thing she does know it's how
much they love to dance
Hanna is a fantastic dancer who wants to
improve her technique but doesn't always
get the chance to in episode 15 Hanna
had a very dramatic moment she started
crying because she didn't get a chance
to prove herself at nationals
the only one who doesn't have a chance
at nationals or Hannah was so obsessed
and all she wanted was a second chance
sabotage pyramid day is never fun unless
you're on top but in episode 8 jimena
felt the burn when she wound up on the
bottom of the pyramid instead of owning
up to her mistakes
Janina chose to blame her group but
obviously the other girls would never do
that because they want to win and
janina's mistakes cost them the title
Jin Nina's accusations hit the moms hard
and they immediately fought back just
another dramatic day at the ALDC lily
storms out competition days are always
damn packed with useless drama and mommy
meltdowns but this time it's Liliana
Ketchum who chose to storm out of the
dressing room Louie's mom Stacy was
fiercely arguing with the other moms in
episode 16 but Lily chose to ignore
their Vickery and focused on perfecting
her routine but the drama caught up to
Lily eventually Ashley and Presley
noticed that Lily was leaking smudges of
paint on the floor and verbally attacked
her for it at this point
Lily couldn't take the tension anymore
and stormed out like a total diva get
your finger out of my face the Abby Lee
dance company and studio 19 have been at
odds for a while now but the fact that
Sara left the studio to compete
alongside the ALDC is something that
Tammy and Katie just don't understand
things got pretty wild when Tammy and
Katie confronted Michelle in the season
8 extended scene because you lied to a
group of women the drama reached an
all-time high when Tammy started
pointing her finger at Michelle's face
calling her a liar studio 19 studio 19
knows exactly what to do to cause
tension at the ALDC
Tammy sent Michelle and Sarah a fruit
basket in episode 14 and its arrival
quickly escalated things studio 19 sent
a note saying that Sarah was always
welcomed at their studio leaving the
moms to pick a fight with Michelle the
moms ganged up on Michelle accusing her
of not taking care of things and Sarah
quickly came to her defense
who knew a fruit basket could cause so
much tension Stacy's tears the ALDC has
no shortage of drama and more often than
not stacy is behind it all she wants
Lily to be number one and frequently
targets those who are doing better than
her during the reunion special the moms
ganged up on Stacy causing her to burst
into tears
I understand Stacy thinks that the other
moms hate her but clearly she's just
being a drama queen
Abby files a police report in an
extended scene from episode 16 we see
Tammy invade Abby's personal space
during a performance and well that was
the last straw for Abby Abby zoomed out
of the competition venue and into a
nearby police station where she filed a
police report against Tammy and her
studio you picked the wrong woman to go
up against Tammy a very humiliated
Michelle in episode 11 Michelle yelled
at her daughter for choosing Abby over
her but poor Sarah was just trying to
land a solo and prove her worth
according to Michelle Abby was trying to
drive a wedge between her and her
daughter I feel like she's poisoning our
relationship and she's trying to divide
us Michelle made Sarah feel guilty and
stressed out she even told Sarah that
she felt humiliated by her actions so
there you have it guys the ten most
dramatic moments in season eight in your
opinion which mom causes the most drama
sound off in the comments give this
video a big thumbs up if you love the og
Dance Moms squad and be sure to
subscribe to the things so you never
miss another video thanks for tuning in
we'll see you next time
[Music]